trois plats
associer les hauts gradés comme les
jeunes recrues les femmes vers les
hommes de terrain comme les
administratifs les élus comme les
experts les syndicats comme les
journalistes les citoyens pour d'abord
posé un diagnostic
et ensuite élaborer des solutions
nouvelles
je tiens ici à remercier le ministre de
l'intérieur
qui est non seulement a saisi cette
occasion unique mais qui n'a pas ménagé
sa peine au delà des urgences et son
quotidien en effet pour avec vous toutes
et tous conduire ces travaux
proposés
devraient pour agir
tout cela en valait la peine car le
résultat est à la dimension des attentes
et les propositions à la hauteur de
l'effroi je le dis pour ceux qui avait
lancé cet exercice je le dis parce que
ces propositions sont le fruit de votre
travail
ce beauvau a d'abord permis de poser un
diagnostic
de revenir sur les dernières années
d'action pour assurer la sécurité des
français le travail mené sous la
houlette de gérard collomb puis
christophe castaner et laurent nunez est
aujourd'hui gérald darmanin et marlène
schiappa
tout n'a pas été parfait
mais pour contacter
nous avons commencé dès 2010 cette part
renforcer l'arsenal de lutte contre le
terrorisme avec l'augmentation des
moyens des services de renseignements
renseignements territoriales comme dg
ainsi qu'ils ont vu leurs effectifs
augmenter de mille neuf cents agents et
leur budget doublé par rapport à 2015
directeur général ici présent le sait ô
combien sa direction n'a pas ménagé sa
peine et à ses côtés toutes les
directions du ministère qui sont engagés
dans cette lutte contre le terrorisme
nous avons procédé à un engagement
massif de la nation il est assumé car il
était nécessaire
en même temps nous avons créé la
coordination nationale du renseignement
et de la lutte contre le terrorisme nous
posions le principe du chef de file à de
la dgs y est promu lyon la loi sécurité
intérieure et lutte contre le terrorisme
qui a permis de sortir de l'état
d'urgence sans désarmer nos services et
la protection de nos concitoyens
nous sommes aujourd'hui mieux armées
juridiquement
techniquement
humainement
mais nous faut continuer inlassablement
ce travail car la menace est là qui
s'adapte se transforme
constamment et c'est bien cette société
de vigilance qui nous faut continuer de
bâtir
je veux en cet instant aussi avoir une
pensée pour
les victimes
et les familles des attentats que la
france a eu à subir en novembre 2015 et
dont nous vivons aujourd'hui les procès
nous avons aussi des 2010 est engagé un
effort sans précédent pour lutter contre
le crime et garantir la sécurité au
quotidien
le budget de la mission sécurité du
ministère a ainsi progressé depuis le
début du quinquennat de 1,7 milliard
d'euros
la création de dix mille postes a été
actée
et achève de se déployer avec les
sorties d'école actuel de même que des
investissements historiques dans
l'équipement et l'immobilier défendre la
sécurité et les forces de sécurité
intérieures ce ne doit plus être des
mots mais bien des actes les actes ce
sont des choix budgétaires ce sont des
décisions ce sont des actions c'est ce
qui s'est passé france relance a aussi
permis d'accélérer encore ce mouvement
fin 2021 plus de 700 casernes et
commissariats auront été modernisé et
30000 véhicule acheté
d'ici le printemps prochain
les deux tiers du parc automobile auront
été changé
onze mille véhicules encore dans les
prochains mois grâce au choix
budgétaires que je fear murray
aujourd'hui
avec des véhicules qui je crois
correspondent sein tout simplement aux
besoins sur le terrain et aussi
à la dignité attendu pour chacune échec
les ministres je dis bien les ministres
car c'est le travail conjoint du
ministre de l'intérieur et le garde des
sceaux sous l'autorité du premier
ministre ont aussi agi pour répondre à
la situation
de violence subie par heure nos forces
de l'ordre la hausse là aussi des
décisions claires et historiques ont été
prises
la fin des remises de peines
pour les auteurs de tels actes
l'incrimination spécifique
pour les auteurs d'actes contre nos
forces de l'ordre qui vient d'être
adoptée il ya quelques semaines
promulguée semaines et enfin
l'observatoire pénale de suivi
de ces violences qui était demandée
depuis tenté tant d'années et qui a été
confirmé et se met en place
c'est une réponse claire
à une situation inadmissible
nous avons enfin pris à bras le corps
les fléaux des temps présents la lutte
contre la drogue avec la création de
l'eau faste une organisation
nationale structure et une coopération
de tous les services des déclinaisons
locales et un travail à l'international
pour démanteler les réseaux les plus
profondément établi le combat contre la
cybercriminalité qui ne touche pas
seulement les infrastructures les plus
critiques les institutions les grandes
entreprises mais aussi les très petites
entreprises
les simples citoyens
un plan a été annoncé dès le printemps
2010 8 qui continue de se déployer
tous ses moyens toutes ces actions
permettent d'abord de rappeler que nous
n'avons pas simplement attendu la
réflexion du beauvau pour agir ou les
débats qui se nouent légitimement au gré
de l'actualité
mais ont aussi conduit à des résultats
qu'il convient de rappeler carré ils
sont le fruit de votre travail
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes
sur le front de la lutte antiterroriste
trente six attentats ont été déjoués par
nos services de renseignement depuis
2010 est en matière de délinquance si
les violences contre les personnes
restent trop élevés chacun constate les
résultats obtenus par la police et la
gendarmerie dans le champ de la
protection des biens
baisse d'un quart des cambriolages
depuis 2017 soit 46 mille 300
habitations cambriolé en moins baisse de
20% de vols de véhicules en moins soit
28 mille victimes de moins
sur le front de la lutte contre la
drogue que j'évoquais il ya un instant
nous progressons aussi de manière
significative
rien que pour le premier semestre de
cette année 37 % de saisies de cannabis
91% de saisies de cocaïne et 60 % de
saisies d'héroïne en plus par rapport à
fait 1837 trafic démantelé ce qui
correspond à une hausse de 34 pour cent
cinquante deux millions d'euros d'avoirs
criminels saisis
ces résultats
c'est le fruit de votre travail et ils
sont incontestables factuel et
vous les avez mené à bien dans un
contexte inédit où l'ensemble de nos
forces de l'ordre ont été largement
mobilisés d'abord dans un contexte de
maintien de l'ordre inédit qui a demandé
énormément de mobilisation et ce depuis
ensuite dans un contexte aussi de lutte
contre l'immigration clandestine et les
réseaux inédite au moment où je vous
parle il y a en plus des moyens
spécifiques qui sont déployés du travail
que fait la paf chaque jour de la
mobilisation exceptionnelle que nous
avons sur certains territoires
ultramarins il ya aujourd'hui quatre
mille policiers et gendarmes aux
frontières hexagonales pour lutter
contre l'immigration clandestine
il n'y en a jamais eu autant
malgré tout cela
il y a les résultats je viens d'évoquer
ses résultats ce sont les vôtres ce sont
des victimes en moins davy qui
s'améliore et je sais combien être
policier gendarme
est un métier difficile fait de risques
mais que vous avez choisi pour cela pour
avoir ses résultats pour bâtir la vie
tranquille et vous pouvez être fiers de
cette action menée que je rappelle un
instant parce que la république est
fière de vous et de cela
simplement tout ne va pas bien non plus
et donc aussi vrai qu'il ne faut pas
céder à la tyrannie des faits divers qui
consisterait à dire que nos forces de
l'ordre ne font rien que nous serions
constamment débordé c'est faux et les
chiffres que je viens de rappeler le
monde il ne faut pas non plus considérer
que tout va bien et que nous pourrions
en rester là ce que les échanges de ce
beau vous confirmer ce que vous dites
ce que vous relatez chaque jour c'est
que ces statistiques ne disent pas tout
de la violence latente qui ces dernières
années s'est emparée de notre société
vous êtes les premières et les premiers
à l'avenir nos concitoyens qui vivent
dans les zones les plus difficiles et
les plus exposés loaded avec vous les
associations engagées le disent aussi
nos élus qui sont au front avec vous sur
ces sujets le relais ces statistiques ne
disent pas tout non de ces faits divers
de plus en plus sordides parfois
barbares même qui endeuillent trop
souvent l'actualité ne disent pas tous
des coups et blessures de violences
intrafamiliales qui sont en croissance
forte
de la délinquance numérique qui explose
et je n'évoque pas les quartiers qui
comme à montpellier marseille je me suis
rendu récemment voit dès groupes cherché
à prendre le pouvoir à imposer leurs
règles sans que jamais nous nice et lyon
mais en reprenant parfois le terrain dès
le lendemain ou le surlendemain
face à ce retour de la violence à cette
transformation de la violence que nous
voyons dans nos sociétés depuis
plusieurs années qui me touchent pas que
la france
nous n'avons droit à aucune complaisance
nous ne devons céder
ni au déni liés à la facilité ne pas
céder au déni parce qu'il serait
évidemment inadmissible de dire que en
quelque sorte cette situation que je
décris ce serait simplement un sentiment
parce qu'il y aurait à côté de ça la
réalité des chiffres les gens qu'ils
vivent vivent des réalités
il faudrait pas non plus considérer que
c'est par une mesure miracle un gadget
est toujours des moyens supplémentaires
nous avons je crois fait ce qu'il
convenait de faire et qui correspondait
à des évaluations établies mais que
telle ou telle mesure permettrait de
tout régler et faire reculer la violence
la transformation est si profonde
cette violence qui prend de plus en plus
de place dans nos sociétés du fait de
mairie de la montée
de l'habitude de l'anonymat d'une
libération de la parole de la
structuration de certains réseaux de la
conjugaison parfois deux phénomènes
multiples appels au contraire
de savoir prendre des décisions profonde
peut être radical de changer nos
habitudes parfois l'ordre établi
de répondre en quelque sorte pas
simplement à vos attentes
à vos propositions
et donc ce que je suis venu vous
annoncer ce matin
7 une stratégie
complète
inspiré de vos travaux préparés par
votre ministre
coopération avec plusieurs membres du
gouvernement en particulier le garde des
sceaux mais qui cherche à répondre en
profondeur à cette évolution
avec d'abord et ce sera le premier
pilier
une réponse
radicale
sur deux sujets la procédure pénale et
le temps long
réponse profonde et radicale parce que
ce sont des sujets dont on parle depuis
longtemps
et
mon souhait est de vous en parler pour
que cela change
nous avons commencé là aussi des progrès
mais nous devons nous nous devons des
changements radicaux
la procédure pénale d'abord j'étais je
l'évoqué à marseille il y as quinzaine
de jours que voit-on
quand on va dans un commissariat une
brigade de gendarmerie
des piles de papiers
à plusieurs reprises je me suis rendu
dans des tribunaux que voit-on
des piles de papier
le combat est le même
le formalisme la lourdeur des procédures
et l'ennemi commun
de nos forces de sécurité de nos magie
il prend du temps du temps d'action du
temps de présence du temps
d'intelligence à déployer ailleurs et on
croirait peut-être que c'est un détail
c'est tout l'inversé derrière ces piles
de papier il y a du temps
excessif qui passaient des procès qui
prennent trop de temps des victimes qui
sont menacés parfois des délinquants en
liberté
derrière ces piles de papier il ya trop
souvent pour vous les premiers mais pour
nous tous
les symptômes d'une impuissance que nos
concitoyens voient
alors là aussi nous avons commencé
d'agir avec des choses très concrètes
qui sont en train de se déployer ont
commencé à être déployées
les fameux rappel à la loi il prenait
tant de temps pour une utilité que
j'aurai la pudeur de ne pas rappeler ici
nous bougeons
180000 rappel la loi que nos policiers
chaque année avait à faire son compte
ainsi supprimer
simplification pour plus d'efficacité en
faisant un choix simple qui a été
construit pour certains faits faut
lancer une procédure qui est plus qu'un
rappel à la loi pour d'autres il faut
acter que c'est le des mini miss mais au
moins aller au bout de la logique et ne
pas rester dans cette hypocrisie qui
vous prend du temps sans avoir quelques
efficacité
la deuxième chose a commencé il ya
maintenant un peu plus d'un an et c'est
un travail qui a commencé il ya trois
ans ce sont les amendes pénales
forfaitaire ces fameuses amendes qui ont
permis d'évoluer là aussi de mettre fin
à des procédures qui étaient trop
longues et donc inefficace et en matière
de lutte contre les stupéfiants est
évoquée depuis septembre 2020
l'amendé forfaitaire a permis d'avancer
je reviendrai sur les chiffres tout à
l'heure de simplifier les choses mais de
mener une vraie politique de pilonnage
sur les points de stups établi avec là
aussi des résultats en seine-saint-denis
à marseille et ailleurs
dans cet instrument a été utilisé et
votre département on est également
l'illustration il produit des résultats
dès ce mois d'octobre nous procéderons à
la même transformation pour répondre à
deux phénomènes très concrets que nos
élus connaissent bien d'abord
l'occupation il les fit par les gens du
voyage de certains terrains
il suffit de lire la presse quotidienne
régionale
pour savoir que nos procédures sont trop
longues
que quand on arrive avec la procédure
requérir le concours de la force
publique c'est parfois déjà trop tard
mais qu'on ne fait pas mal là où ça fait
vraiment mal cette porte monnaie pardon
d'être trivial et directe et donc on va
faire gagner du temps à beaucoup de
monde on va alléger de la procédure mais
on va permettre aussi de répondre à des
situations inacceptables sur le terrain
en ayant la même approche par les
amendes pénales forfaitaire pour
l'occupation illicite par les gens du
voyage des terrains et nous allons faire
la même chose pour un autre sujet qui
hante la vie de nos concitoyens de
beaucoup d'associations et beaucoup
d'élus les occupations illicites de
halls d'immeuble sur ces deux sujets
nous allons là aussi procédé à la mise
en place de cette même amende
ça ne veut pas dire que nous changeons
les garanties apportées dans notre droit
7 mende et pénales mais nous simplifions
la procédure et nous permettons
d'avancer et de répondre aux besoins de
sécurité et aux besoins qui est le vôtre
aussi c'est à dire d'avoir un résultat
tangible
aux décisions que vous prenez sur le
terrain et à la situation vous pouvez
constater
nous avons engagé également la mise en
place de la procédure pénale numérique
qui est une véritable révolution en
terme d'organisation et de
simplification et que nous continuerons
de parachever ce travail a donc bien
commencé
avec des premiers résultats mais il est
insuffisant nous devons aller beaucoup
plus loin
policiers gendarmes magistrats vous
continuez à vous épuiser à respecter des
procédures il faut bien le dire qu'ils
sont quand même souvent hors d'âge
où on multiplie les pv où il y un
formalisme des auditions qui ne tient
compte d'aucun moyen technologique
actuelle
d'aucune des formes de garanties qu'on
utilise par ailleurs pour tout le reste
de la vie publique et des sécurités
qu'on sait maintenant apporter pour
tenter tant d'actes avec des textes qui
sont aussi parfois contradictoires et
pendant ce temps les délinquants qui eux
jouent de lourdeur et avance je ne
pouvons plus laisser prospérer une telle
situation
le droit doit protéger les citoyens
évidemment tous les citoyens doivent
être protégés il ne s'agit pas de
sacrifier ce que sont les fondements de
nos procédures parce qu'elles permettent
de garantir aussi
le droit des victimes comme ceux des
inculpés
mais pour autant nul ne serait accepté
de rendre l'état impuissant
le droit doit être au service de nos
principes
jamais de l'inefficacité
c'est pourquoi à court terme
fort de vos travaux et de ce qui a été
mis en place
je demande au garde des sceaux
d'élaborer sous un mois un bilan des
mesures de simplification engagé depuis
le début du quinquennat et de faire des
propositions pour améliorer rapidement
le travail des enquêteurs
magistrats et de l'ensemble des forces
d'ici trois mois de proposer un
complément de mesures très concrètes de
simplification de nos procédures pénales
mais le chantier plus vaste nous savons
bien et il ne peut pas se faire en trois
ou quatre mois il faut être lucide et là
je vous dois l'honnêteté on vous l'a
tant promis
et il faut bien aussi constaté que les
évolutions de la société conduisent
parfois à alourdir ce qu'on voudrait
même allégé et il se peut même que les
dernières lois et parfois contribué à
alourdir certaines de cv procédure
j'allais bien en tête et je le vois
comme vous donc c'est une remise à plat
plus large qu'il nous faut faire au-delà
de ces premiers travaux c'est pourquoi
dans le cadre des états généraux de la
justice qui vont s'ouvrir dans quelques
semaines et qui sont intimement liés à
ceux beauvau de la sécurité car la
mission régalienne à quelque chose
d'inséparables même si nos principes
peuvent respecter chacun lors logique
dans le cadre de ces états généraux de
la justice je souhaite que le garn
puisse réunir parlementaires magistrats
professeur de droit avocat forces de
l'ordre pour repenser les grands
équilibres de la procédure pénale est
proposé une nouvelle écriture du code
je ne vais pas ici préempter les débats
mais il ya quelques éléments simples sur
lequel je demande que nous puissions
avancer dans ce cadre une simplification
drastique des cadres d' enquête qui peut
encore
comprendre la multiplication de ces
cadres entre la flagrance d' enquêtes
préliminaires et la multiplication des
formalismes et parfois des répétitions
la généralisation des pv de synthèse
pour les petits délits
et le débat nécessaire sur l'utilisation
aussi des nouveaux moyens qui sont
offerts aux enquêteurs dans le cadre des
procédures pour permettre
d'éviter les saisines parfois longues
de longs entretiens qui ont pu être
filmés ou suivi
ces sujets
sont tous extrêmement lourd je ne sous
estime pas mais il mérite mieux que de
débats d'estrade parce que la cause est
commune parce que c'est du temps de
policiers de gendarmes
c'est du temps de magistrats c'est du
temps de personnels administratifs qui
pourrait être beaucoup mieux utiliser
qui nous savions prendre chacun de ces
sujets comment doit les prendre c'est ce
que je demande donc dans le cadre de ces
états généraux de faire pour compléter
les mesures de court terme sur lesquels
je viens d'ores et déjà de m'engager en
quelque sorte poursuivre sur la voie du
pragmatisme parce que c'est ce qu'on
vous doit mieux que le la démagogie des
propos d'estrade ou des mesures magique
parce que j'ai la faiblesse de penser
que s'il y avait une mesure magique
depuis tant d'années elle aurait déjà
été décidées
le second changement radical que je veux
ici engagée
concerne le temps dans lequel s'inscrit
votre action
on dit souvent du ministère de
l'intérieur qui les ministères de
l'urgence ce ministre
sur les directeurs et préfet vous ne me
démentirait pas vous répondait toujours
présent quand l'imprévu est là avec
force quand tout semble s'effondrer vous
êtes les visites de la république mais
le ministère de l'intérieur a aussi
besoin de temps long
de durée d'inscription
justement dans le temps et
d'anticipation et je vous le dis avec
beaucoup d'humilité parce que j'ai vu
aussi le temps que prennent les
décisions
quand je me suis engagé au printemps
2017 à déployer dix mille forces de
police supplémentaires beaucoup de gens
il ya encore 18 ou 24 mois mais qui sont
vos dix mille policiers et gendarmes
il faut les former pour les retraités en
faire passer les concours les formes et
cela prend du temps et donc on ne peut
pas piloter le politique de sécurité
à l'embardée au volant à l'émotion vous
valez mieux que ça notre nation vaut
mieux que ça et il faut donc que nous en
créons nos stratégies dans le temps long
en matière de moyens de formation
d'engagement
voilà pourquoi j'ai décidé que nous
porterons une loi de programmation pour
la sécurité intérieure et même pour les
sécurités intérieur car il s'agit de
tout le champ d'action de la place
beauvau
le but est de penser la police et la
gendarmerie de 2030 une police qui doit
faire face aux nouvelles formes de
délinquance qui pullulent dans l'espace
numérique le deal par messagerie crypté
les escroqueries digital la
cybercriminalité une police qui doit se
saisir des technologies numériques pour
aller plus vite enquêter plus
efficacement une police qui doit être
formé et équipé en fonction des
nouvelles menaces qui pèsent sur la
société le terrorisme mais aussi la
violence débridée les manifestations
sporadiques
l'internationalisation du crime
le champ n'a jamais été si vaste
nous devons y répondre en regardant le
temps long et en prenant des choix qui
dureront et l'assument
c'est pourquoi je demande au ministre de
l'intérieur
de préparer l'élaboration de cette loi
de programmation qui sera assorti des
moyens nécessaires que je souhaite voir
présenté en conseil des ministres au
début de l'année 2022 fait loi
devra être la loi de modernisation
numérique du ministère de l'intérieur
là aussi nous avons besoin d'une
véritable révolution des pratiques du
quotidien du suivi de l'action le
ministre a montré ses compétences en la
matière lui qui a réussi la réforme de
l'impôt à la source je compte donc sur
vous monsieur le ministre pour réussir
le même virage au ministère de
l'intérieur c'est-à-dire restructurer en
profondeur
cette action numérique elle est
nécessaire
par cette réécriture de la procédure
pénale par cette loi de programmation
qui sera assortie de moyens la nation et
donc aux côtés de sa police et de la
gendarmerie pas un mot
pas en bricolage
en profondeur
avec des choix clairs des engagements
concrets de court terme de moyen terme
de long terme
parce que la nation est à vos côtés et
je vous le dis avec à la fois solennité
respect et affection
écoutez toujours les critiques chacune
et chacun d'entre nous doit le faire
pour nous améliorer constamment
n'écoutez jamais les cris de haine ils
sont indignes les français vous m la
nation vous n
en retour de l'effort historique que
nous avons consentis que nous engageons
ce jour je veux aussi c'est pour moi le
deuxième pilier de cette stratégie
d'ensemble fixé deux ambitions claires
qui ne sont pas celles du ministère mais
qui sont les ambitions des français les
exigences au fond qui ont pu
être exprimée dans le cadre des
consultations largement mené
la première exigence est ambitieux je
lis parfois d'ailleurs dit en ces termes
je vous le répète plus de bleus sur le
terrain
ce qu'attendent nos compatriotes
c'est en effet une présence accrue de
policiers et de gendarmes sur la voie
publique parce que c'est rassurant pour
eux et dissuasif pour le délinquant
alors nous avons déjà beaucoup fait en
la matière nous avons créé des postes de
policiers et de gendarmes
nous avons embauché des personnels
administratifs
nous avons mis en place ces terminaux
numériques qui diminue le temps au
bureau
l'allègement aussi de certaines tâches
la fameuse création d' amendes
forfaitaires qui sur la seule
consommation de stupéfiants où elle est
en place depuis maintenant un an a
permis 100000 amendes dressées 100000
depuis le 1er septembre 2020 tout cela a
permis de déployer plus de temps utile
et la logique engagé dès le début de mon
mandat police de sécurité au quotidien
dégager des fonctions inutiles
embauchée nous en avons les résultats
d'ores et déjà aujourd'hui mais nous
devons aller plus loin en sachant là
aussi bousculé quelques tabous quelques
habitudes prises et je veux nous fixer
un horizon
augmenter significativement
c'est à dire doubler sous dix ans la
présence des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique
cet objectif nous pouvons le tenir il
faudra peut-être
créé des postes ici ou là en fonction
justement ce que les travaux qui
présideront à la loppsi permettront
d'identifier mais nous avons la
possibilité de dégager des marges de
manoeuvre par des réformes en profondeur
et des exigences
il flow dégagé pour cela les policiers
des tâches administratives en
développant les missions des personnels
administratifs
il faut aussi réexaminer le temps de
travail pour renforcer la capacité des
unités de terrain
les cycles horaires sont devenus
illisibles
et je demande en la matière qu'un
travail de fond soit engagée en lien
avec les représentants des personnels
pour que l' équilibre de vie des agents
et la présence sur le terrain se
conjuguent mais les cycles horaires ne
correspondent plus aux besoins du
terrain à ce que vivent nos concitoyens
et même à ce pour quoi vous vous êtes
engagé soyons clairs c'est le fruit de
discussions où il n'y avait pas assez de
moyens pas assez d'ambition et il
fallait passer des mauvais compromis
fini le temps des mauvais compromis il y
a une ambition on a commencé à mettre
les moyens on va aller au bout de cette
logique avec les moyens il doit y avoir
aussi de l'exigence je demande que le
ministre puisse conduire ces discussions
sur les nouveaux cycles horaires pour
que d'ici au 1er janvier prochain elle
soit finalisée
nous allons aussi revoir le système
de mouvements nomination là aussi
ça ne correspond plus aux besoins du
terrain je vous parle en toute franchise
je crois que nous le savons tous au fond
on ne peut plus en effet faire venir
sans personnel en renfort pendant une
année
et l'année suivante les laisser partir
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui avec
les mouvements tels qu'ils sont
organisés
les nominations doivent s'inscrire
d'abord dans la durée les mutations
doivent se faire en fonction des besoins
du terrain tels qu'ils sont évalués par
la hiérarchie par l'analyse en lien avec
les élus de ses besoins là aussi je
demande que le ministre puisse mener les
discussions et qu'elle soit finalisée au
1er janvier prochain
j'ai conscience de l'exigence qu'il ya
derrière ces réformes mais elles sont
nécessaires
la deuxième ambition et exigence
c'est de mieux prendre en charge les
victimes
nous avons là encore fait beaucoup
notamment pour mieux prendre en charge
les femmes victimes de violences la
création du 39 19 aujourd'hui accessible
24 heures sur 24 et j'en remercie les
équipes la formation de près de 90 mille
policiers et gendarmes
la mise en place de guichets dédiés le
déploiement de 2300 téléphone graves
dangers pour les victimes
la création de 123 postes d'intervenants
sociaux supplémentaires
nous devons nous inspirer de cette
méthode pour mieux accompagner
l'ensemble des victimes
mais aujourd'hui nous devons encore
faire mieux pour
en quelque sorte nous mettre au plus
près des victimes et leur permettre
d'avoir accès aux services du quotidien
que d'autres services publics savent
leur rendre
et donc la police et la gendarmerie
françaises doivent prendre le virage du
service rendu aux citoyens
pour ce faire je souhaite que la plainte
en ligne soient mises en oeuvre dès 2023
et pas seulement l'après plainte comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
je souhaite que dans ce cadre un suivi
soit possible pour les victimes avec des
référents à qui s'adressait au sein des
forces de l'ordre et des applications
numériques dédiés c'est important pour
les victimes mais c'est important aussi
pour les forces sur le terrain pour vous
tous et toutes de pouvoir suivre les
affaires et leur progression
je souhaite qu'au delà des femmes
victimes de violences toutes celles et
tous ceux qui veulent porter plainte
soit mieux accueilli ce qui suppose tout
à la fois de mieux formés et continuer à
mieux aménager nos commissariats et
nobrega
voilà les deux exigences indispensables
que nous devons aussi ensemble
travailler et pour lesquels nous devons
avoir des résultats dans les prochains
mois
alors qu'il faut penser loin
et si nous souhaitons ensemble avancés
avec ces deux ambitions je n'oublie pas
pour autant les urgences que vous avez
exprimé durant ce beauvau je n'oublie
pas votre quotidien fait de manque de
moyens d'agressions répétées de défiance
parfois insupportable j'ai rappelé il y
à quelques instants ce qui a déjà été
fait pour répondre à ces violences pour
répondre aussi aux besoins sur le
terrain
mais au delà nous devons
aller plus loin
prendre à bras le corps cette situation
et continuer de nous engager en 2022 le
ministère de l'intérieur verra ainsi son
budget augmenter de près de 1,5 milliard
d'euros dont 500 millions d'euros pour
la mise en oeuvre des premières mesures
du beauvau de la sécurité c'est sans
précédent
95 %
95 % de ces mesures qui ressorte du
beauvau sont pour du matériel de
l'investissement les conditions de
travail je le dis ça n'est que
extrêmement marginalement du
catégorielles une fois encore parce que
bien souvent ce qui avait été le parent
pauvre pour vous c'était cela les
conditions de travail
les voitures la situation des bâtiments
tout ce qui faisait le quotidien la
performance la dignité le sens du métier
et ça permettra d'abord d'investir dans
l'humain à court terme qui en matière de
sécurité est la base de tout nous le
savons nous sommes ici dans une école
merci de nous accueillir madame la
directrice
mais ça commence à l'école et c'est tout
au long de la carrière la sécurité c'est
d'abord le travail de femmes et d'hommes
on donne plus de moyens il ya plus de
technique il ya des technologies qui
s'installe de plus en plus et ça
continuera
mais ce sont des femmes des hommes qui
s'engagent et qui croient dans ça
il croit dans cette fonction c'est ce
que vous faites est donc je dirais que
trop longtemps nous n'avons pas investi
dans l'humain
j'ai d'abord entendu votre souhait
légitime de bénéficier d'un temps plus
long de formation et d'avoir une réponse
plus adaptée en termes de formation
d'abord et je dois dire que j'ai
découvert cela à la lecture des travaux
du beauvau je confesse on apprend
toujours
quand on passe un concours on attend
deux ans en moyenne pour entrer dans
l'école
bon courage
les jeunes les plus motivés
sont évidemment du coup ceux qui
hésitent parfois quand ils ont plusieurs
concours ils rejoignent d'autres
administrations d'autres services tout
le monde est perdant à ce jeu
il nous faut nous fixer un objectif
six mois maximum entre l'obtention du
concours et l'entrée dans l'école c'est
le maximum c'est ce qui peut être
accepté par un jeune et sa famille plus
on perd le sens et surtout on tue tout à
toute attractivité c'est aussi pour cela
que nous avons décidé de mettre des
moyens l'académie de police je lui ai
annoncé à montpellier
dans laquelle passeront l'ensemble
l'ensemble de mes forces de police en
france mais également des centres
régionaux et centres spécialisés pour
nos policiers et nos gendarmes pour
compléter l'offre d'ores et déjà
existantes et répondre à la formation
initiale dans les temps nécessaires et à
la formation continue
je pense aussi qu'il est nécessaire
d'entendre ce qui ressort de vos travaux
la formation n'est pas assez longue et
qualifiante
j'ai donc décidé dès l'année prochaine
d'augmenter de 4 mois le temps de
formation initiale des gardiens de la
paix et de hausser de 50% la durée de la
formation continue pour les gendarmes et
les policiers
c'est indispensable
ces temps de formation seront considérés
comme du temps de travail à part entière
sanctuarisé par votre hiérarchie et
valoriser financièrement comme tel
à chaque fois que nous avons eu des
difficultés sur le terrain nous le
savons bien c'est qu'il manquait du
monde et c'est qu'il y avait des manques
de formation face à telle ou telle
situation est ce qu'on peut reprocher à
nos forces de l'ordre de ne pas avoir
été formés sur telle ou telle situation
d'avoir déployé des jeunes ou moins
jeunes sur des situations auxquelles ils
n'avaient pas été dûment préparé
nous y répondrons par cet engagement et
ses moyens mis sur la formation
cela permettra ensuite d'accéder aux
demandes légitimes
formulées durant ce beauvau par les
différents corps de métiers de la police
et de la gendarmerie nationale
ceux d'entre vous qui appartiennent aux
forces de sécurité publique ont souligné
durant les tables rondes l'utilité des
caméras piétons qui permettent en
opération d'éviter tout dérapage d
interpeller des qui lorsqu une
interpellation se passe mal sont des
outils de levée de doute
j'en suis profondément convaincu c'est
un outil qui dissuade et c'est un outil
qui protège tout le monde nous n'avons
rien à perdre avec la transparence en
permanence et c'est un outil qui permet
aussi de recontextualiser les choses
combien de fois avons nous vu des vidéos
volet sortie de tout contexte qui est
émise par tel ou tel en ligne et qui
devenait
soudainement un matériau journalistique
le fruit de tous les commentaires sans
qu'il y ait la possible et de remettre
dans ce contexte dans son contexte ce
qui s'était passé
les caméras sont bonnes pour l'action
pour prévenir des violences
mais aussi dans la suite judiciaire qui
sera donné alors il faut déployer et là
aussi il faut former parce qu'il faut
bien encadrer l'utilisation de ces
caméras pour qu'elle puisse ensuite être
utilisés dans les procédures et nous
connaissons toutes les contraintes c'est
pourquoi je vous confirme d'abord la
finalisation du déploiement d'une caméra
piétons par patrouille vous le savez j'y
crois
quinze mille ont déjà été déployés
quinze mille restent à déployer deux le
seront d'ailleurs dans les prochaines
semaines d'ici à octobre l'ensemble des
engagements pris en la matière de ses
trente mille caméras seront toutes
déployés c'est une véritable révolution
je rassure aussi pour les plus experts
que nous avons changé les contrats jadis
passé et que pour ceux qui n'en n'ont
pas encore bénéficié ne s'agit plus des
formidables caméra qui marchait quatre
heures par jour
j'ai pu voir dans d'autres pays qu'il y
avait des caméras qui marchait tout le
temps du service c'est bien celle ci qui
sont déployés le contrat passé a été
cassée dans mon passé de nouveaux
marchés et c'est bien une caméra qui
correspond à vos besoins qui est ainsi
déployés
mais ce vers quoi nous devons aller
d'ici à la fin 2022 c'est de permettre à
ce que chaque fonctionnaire sur le
terrain soit doté d'une caméra
individuelle cet objectif nous pouvons
atteindre nous allons l'atteindre c'est
l'engagement que nous devons nous donner
à nous mêmes je vous confirme également
que nous allons engager le déploiement
des caméras embarquées pour les
véhicules qui supposait changements
législatifs
celui ci est en train de se part achevé
et la mesure pourrait être effective dès
le déploiement de ces caméras
d'ores et déjà
pour les patrouilles ensuite pour
chacune et chacun d'entre vous puis pour
les véhicules c'est une stratégie
de dissuasion c'est une stratégie de
transparence
c'est une stratégie
d'efficacité et de protection pour vous
toutes et tous
celle ci est complété par l'engagement
aussi de nos élus je veux ici les
remercier les collectivités
territoriales se mobilisent aussi
continuerons de le faire en particulier
pour les réseaux de vidéoprotection je
tiens à saluer les contributions de la
mfd associations d'élus au beauvau de la
sécurité nos élus sont en première ligne
et avec le déploiement des vidéo
protection qui a continué de se
renforcer avec aussi le travail qui a
été fait pour renforcer la coopération
entre nos police municipale et la police
nationale la gendarmerie nationale et le
travail de notre justice est
indispensable et c'est là aussi un
continuum auquel nous tenons
vous avez aussi souvent fait part du
manque d'attractivité des métiers pour
la police judiciaire si je continue à
parcourir et à cheminer à travers les
différents métiers de la police et de la
gendarmerie
et seulement que d'attractivité nous
ressentons avec flotter sur le terrain
plusieurs départements où la criminalité
ne manquent pas où la délinquance est
forte on un problème c'est souvent le
manque d'eau pj
et donc la difficulté pour que les
procédures avance comme il se devrait
je souhaite comme l'a proposé le
ministre qu'un plan pour l'investigation
soit lancé dès la fin de cette année
la formation dopée j sera intégré à la
formation initiale de tout policier et
tout gendarme ce qui permettra de
participer au premier acte d' enquêtes
et de fiabiliser ainsi les procédures
c'est un changement profond qui suppose
un changement de notre code de procédure
pénale qui je le rappelle faisait je
parle sous le contrôle de nos directeurs
attendre au moins trois ans tout jeune
fonctionnaire pour pouvoir prétendre
devenir au pgi chacun sera fort mais ça
ne veut pas dire que tout le monde de
réussir à l'examen ça après ça dépend de
chacune et chacun mais ce sera dans la
base de formation de tous tous sans
conditions ce qui permettra une bien
plus grande efficacité une acculturation
de tous mais surtout évidemment
une démultiplication
de notre pays sur le terrain c'est
indispensable et là aussi ce travail
sera poursuivi dans le cadre des états
généraux de la justice par aussi tout le
rapprochement entre la formation de nos
forces de sécurité intérieure et des
magistrats qui je crois est un axe
important dont le garde des sceaux se
saisira en lien avec le ministre de
l'intérieur
une partie du personnel administratif
agira par ailleurs comme des greffiers
de police et de gendarmerie ce qui
permettra de dégager du temps aux
enquêteurs spécialisés
c'est pour nos personnels administratifs
et techniques
la possibilité d'une évolution
importante qui vient s'ajouter au plan
de revalorisation d'ores et déjà
annoncés et je pense que c'est important
et cela a du sens et je le dis pour
l'ensemble de nos personnels
administratifs et techniques qui font
partie de la famille police et de la
famille gendarmerie à part entière eux
qui d'ailleurs à magnanville à la
préfecture de police ou à rambouillet
ont payé ces dernières années un si
lourd tribut
dans le domaine de l'ordre public
que les phénomènes nouveaux de ces
dernières années que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure rapidement black block gilet
jaune manifestations sporadiques ont
profondément bousculé et n'ont pas
ménagé
les défis que le bobo a mises en avant
sont nombreux et là aussi nous y
répondrons
après avoir repensé le schéma national
de maintien de l'ordre après avoir
renforcé de 600 effectif
nos unités de forces mobiles
travail qui a permis de reconstituer
quatre unités nous allons créer en
région parisienne un centre de formation
dédié aux policiers comme un gendarme
ce nouveau centre permettra de
constituer un vivier pour créer deux
nouvelles compagnies de crs et escadrons
de gendarmerie mobile pour répondre aux
besoins
sur le sujet des relations
entre forces de l'ordre et presse il a
aussi a été en particulier l'hiver
dernier fortement commentée qui a été
aussi discuté durant les tables rondes
et qui est un point important la
confiance entre la nation et ses forces
de sécurité
je souhaite que les propositions du
rapport de la rue retenu par le premier
ministre soient mises en oeuvre dans les
plus brefs délais ce rapport a fait un
travail exhaustif
impartiale la nouvelle version du schéma
national du maintien de l'ordre qui sera
présentée avant novembre permettra ainsi
de décliner les conclusions de ce
rapport elle permettra de consacrer la
place et le rôle des journalistes mais
d'imposer aussi à toutes les parties
prenantes présente dans une
manifestation où à l'issue d'une
manifestation des règles qui vont avec
ces situations exceptionnelles comme il
se doit
pas d'hypocrisie pour personne
dans le secteur de la police technique
et scientifique
nos experts qui est indispensable à la
résolution des enquêtes sont reconnus
comme les tous meilleurs du monde
verront leurs équipements est remise à
niveau pour améliorer leur visibilité
sur les lieux dans kate et leur
protection
l'ensemble des agents de la pts comme on
l'appelle bénéficiera par ailleurs d'un
nouveau statut c'est là aussi le fruit
du travail et des concertations menées
ces derniers mois
enfin par delà les spécialités
durant ce beauvau beaucoup de choses
très concrètes remontant du terrain ont
été dites sur lesquels nous allons agir
d'abord la présence aussi sur le terrain
de la hiérarchie
beaucoup ont dit partager le fait qu' il
fallait encourager davantage les
promotions internes mais il fallait
qu'il y ait beaucoup plus de hiérarchie
sur le terrain ce qui va avec le plus de
bleu aussi dans nos rues
l'organisation des forces sera donc revu
pour réhausser le taux d'encadrement et
permettre un commandement 24 heures sur
24 et 7 jours sur 7
c'est indispensable et je sais
d'ailleurs l'engagement de tous le
commandement de la hiérarchie qui prône
pour aller en ce sens et donc c'est un
travail de réorganisation
collective du travail c'est aussi un
engagement pour plus de promotions
internes
sur le modèle de ce qui a été
expérimenté outre-mer et dans trois
départements des directions
départementales de la police nationale
seront créées dans chaque département
ceci permettra de lutter contre la
logique des silos et d'organiser pour
que là aussi entre toutes les
composantes le travail se fasse de
manière beaucoup plus simple
j'ai entendu aussi les préoccupations
qui remontaient sur l'image sur
l'uniforme
désuet inappropriée et ceci je ne sous
estime pas parce que c'est une question
de fierté de respect ça va avec
les locaux la situation de
conditions de travail au quotidien avec
le véhicule
j'ai vu la fierté dans les regards quand
on a déployé les premiers véhicules et
que vos directeurs départementaux le
directeur général le ministre était là
il change ils vont plus vite ils sont
plus confortables mais surtout ils sont
reconnus en ville
respecter il en est de même pour
l'uniforme toutes les écoles de design
et bac professionnel métiers de la mode
de france ont été invités au printemps
2021 à l'initiative de votre ministre a
proposé une modernisation de la tenue
des polices deux propositions ont été
retenues et ont débouché après
échanges avec vos représentants un
prototype de polo moderniser d'un calot
qui remplacera la casquette
ces nouvelles pièces fabriquées en
france seront mises en production est
distribué au premier trimestre 2011 22
le ministre aura l'occasion avec dgpn de
vous le présenter en détail et de
déployer cela mais cela participe de ce
renouveau de la police française et de
la considération qui vous est dû
j'ai entendu aussi
lorsque il était dit que nos policiers
et nos gendarmes que pour beaucoup de
choses bien souvent
il manquait de bras dans des situations
d'urgence ou l'engagement pour être
peut-être mieux sollicités c'est
pourquoi pour vous épauler dans vos
missions une réserve opérationnelle de
la police sera créée et dotée de 30000
réservistes quant à la réserve de
l'agenda remise de la gendarmerie
nationale qui elle existe déjà
elle accueillera vingt mille personnes
supplémentaires
création d'une réserve donc pour notre
police doublement dans le cadre de la
loppsi
2 la réserve pour la gendarmerie
je vous ai aussi entendu
souligné que vous préfériez un contrôle
plus strict et plus transparent de votre
activité plutôt qu'une défiance
généralisée et qu'un soupçon permanent
soyons clairs et là dessus je tiens à
leur dire quand on aime les forces de
l'ordre on ne leur passe pas tout
c'est pas vrai
c'est pas vrai il aurait pas d'un côté
ceux qui défendent le force de les
forces de l'ordre en disant dès qu'il ya
un problème on est du côté des forces de
l'ordre et de l'autre côté décrit un
problème ceux qui lisent moi je suis du
côté des citoyens c'est forcément les
policiers les gendarmes qui ont tort il
faut les massacres et médiatiquement
c'est le débat auquel en a t'il depuis
tant d'années non dans la république il
ya des forces de l'ordre qui sont là
pour servir
la loi républicaine et elles méritent le
soutien et la confiance puisque ça
l'engagement de la nation que je vous
dis depuis tout à l'heure
avec la confiance il ya l'exigence et je
sais que c'est ce que vous quand il ya
des fautes elles doivent être
sanctionnées quand il ya des problèmes
ils ont une réponse
et comme nous n'avons pas de sujet avec
la transparence et le sens des
responsabilités
on doit aller au bout
mais sortons de cette espèce de fracas
dans lesquelles le débat médiatique nous
enferme
et qui en vient à faiblir tout le monde
et surtout la confiance légitime alors
je le dis d'abord pour celles et ceux
qui l'ignorent quand je regarde
l'ensemble des agents publics
il n'y en a pas autant que vous qui
souffre qui font l'objet de sanctions
c'est que ça fonctionne
quand je regarde la concentration des
sanctions qui lie à faire des agents
publics on parle plutôt de votre
ministère
que la responsabilité s'exerce avec la
même efficacité partout c'est ce à quoi
je veillerai et je continuerai trier
mais surtout nous n'avons rien à
craindre d'une transparence accrue et
d'une plus grande vigilance dans le
suivi de ce qui émerge c'est pourquoi
j'avais demandé certains l'avaient mal
green feignant de ne pas le comprendre
il avait dit me dit qu'il ya des
problèmes
mettons en place une plateforme qui
permettent de voir s'il ya des problèmes
et où il se passe et s'il y en a nous
procéderons à des sanctions c'est
pourquoi la défenseure des droits que je
remercie pour son engagement et son
travail a mis en place une plate forme
de signalement des discriminations le 12
février dernier elle a été créée
permettant de signaler toutes les
discriminations et de répondre à des
polémiques qui montait sur le terrain
ça permet de faire remonter d'ailleurs
toutes les discriminations
ce dont on s'aperçoit c'est qu'il y en a
beaucoup trop
7564 appel recensés entre le 12 février
et le 31 août
il y en a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
trop
il y en a beaucoup en matière d'emploi
en matière de logement
mais à 4 % des appels qui concerne les
forces de l'ordre et leur déontologie
alors sur chacun de ces appels j'ai
demandé aux ministres de veiller à ce
que il y ait un travail qu'ils soient
faits pour comprendre ce qu'il ya
derrière mener les enquêtes internes et
si besoin était et procédures mais ce
chiffre permet d'objectiver une chose de
réactiver une chose
il n'y a pas non plus des dizaines de
milliers de problèmes sur ce sujet ou
alors il faut qu'on continue à appeler
la plateforme mais au moins
avons un chiffre objectif qui est
explicitée par une autorité
administrative indépendante
cela démontre que les forces de l'ordre
dans leur immense majorité font preuve
de déontologie et de discernement et
comme je le disais nous devons tendre à
l'irréprochabilité et il y a parfois des
problèmes c'est vrai
voilà pourquoi
répondre à cela l'exigence de nos
concitoyens je souhaite que nous
inventions sur plusieurs sujets qui
correspond d'ailleurs à
la maturité sur ces questions de
déontologie de contrôle interne et qui
est le pendant d'une plus grande un voeu
d'un plus grand investissement dans la
formation que j'évoquais c'est pourquoi
lé rapport de l'igpn et de l'hygiène
seront désormais rendu publics
transparence toujours et que les
directeurs généraux chargés de prendre
systématiquement une décision suite aux
propositions de sanctions
seront mobilisés
sanctions qui peuvent aussi donner lieu
à des réorganisations de services et de
le faire dans le mois qui suit leur
publication sur ce sujet je veux être
clair
une inspection générale n'est pas une
autorité administrative indépendante j'y
ai beaucoup réfléchi je pense que les
inspections doivent avoir un statut à
part au sein des directions c'est
légitime et cela va avec les personnes
qui les dirigent mais elles doivent être
un instrument pour les directeurs et
directrices et pour les ministres pour
vrai sinon il n'y a plus de commandes
je crois au commandement et à la
responsabilité d'avoir du commandement
donc il ya quelqu'un qui décide et qui
nomme simplement transparence des
rapports et transparence sur le suivi de
ces rapports qui devront donner lieu à
des décisions claires
personnel ou organisationnelles
voilà pourquoi aussi je proposerai au
président deux chambres parlementaires
que sur le modèle de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement soit
créer une instance ii troll
parlementaire des forces de l'ordre qui
pourra procéder à l'évaluation de leur
action
soutient
investissements
et exigences et transparence je crois
que c'est ce vers quoi nous devons
continuer d'avancer sans crainte mais
pour réconforter
bâtir plus avant ce socle de confiance
avec la nation qui est indispensable
mesdames et messieurs cette
transformation d'ampleur que nous menons
est bien sûr une transformation qui vise
avant tout à améliorer la vie de nos
compatriotes
c'est un mouvement profond
qui doit permettre de reconquérir par
tous ces espaces de vie tranquille ce
droit à la vie tranquille c'est ce que
chaque français et chaque français
souhaite
je ne mésestime aucune difficulté aucun
problème aucun coût du quotidien vous
les connaissez comme moi nous y faisons
face
mais nous devons continuer d'avancer
vers cet horizon à leur service mais
c'est aussi une transformation et une
ambition je dirai
au service de votre engagement
quand on décide d'être policier ou
gendarme on n'embrasse pas simplement
une fonction ou un métier
on embrasse un engagement de vie je le
dis encore une fois dans une école et en
regardant nos plus jeunes
on le fait en sachant les risques qu'on
prend
sur le terrain on le fait en engageant
une famille qui va vivre avec ce risque
toute la vie on le fait avec des
contraintes et des servitudes de chaque
jour mais parce qu'on y croit
et pour moi cette ambition ce travail
qui sort du bureau de la sécurité c'est
pour que nous soyons aussi
collectivement à la hauteur
des rêves et de l'engagement qu'ils ont
été et doivent rester les vôtres parce
qu'une nation a besoin de femmes et
d'hommes qui croient dans cet engagement
pour la vie cannes
et tranquille
ne cédez rien à ce besoin de sens que
vous avez de considération
parce que c'est ce qui tient la
république
et ce qui est plus grand que nous et
chacune et chacun vous servez quelque
chose de plus grand que nous
qui est justement la force de la loi
sa force
sans brutalité
au service de nos principes de notre
histoire de ce que nous sommes
cet engagement est ce sens auquel vous
tenez tant c'est ce pourquoi nous nous
battons parce que votre dévouement à la
patrie nous oblige c'est pourquoi vous
l'avez compris aujourd'hui en sortant de
ce nouveau de la sécurité je voulais
avec vous embrasser une ambition
nouvelle des chantiers nouveaux
mais aussi des exigences légitimes
et le faire avec vous au service de nos
concitoyens
pro patria vigilance pour la patrie il
veille c'est la force des policiers
pour la patrie l'honneur et le droit
c'est l'engagement des gendarmes
au nom du peuple français
c'est la légitimité des magistrats
parce que tous ensemble
nous sommes au service
du peuple français
parce que chacune et chacun d'entre vous
portent une part
de cette responsabilité je crois comme
vous dans un état qui protège et qui
libère je crois comme vous à une
autorité qui n'a pas de qualificatifs
parce qu'au fond elle doit toujours être
républicaine
vive la police nationale vive la
gendarmerie nationale vive la république
et vive la france
[Applaudissements]
à nous de faire